[Music]
one of the biggest news stories of this
tumultuous year was the demand for
police reform
massive demonstrations were seen in
cities all across the country including
here in las vegas
does metro need to be reformed and if so
in what ways
this week 8 news now is looking at the
progress metro has made in the past few
years and how far
it still needs to go the i-team's george
knapp starts it off
on the streets of las vegas as in other
major cities protesters demanded police
reform their anger fueled by flash
points
such as the death of george floyd at the
hands of police
across the nation long simmering anger
at police
began as peaceful protests but erupted
into something else
it did make me sick to my stomach that a
singular officer
could cause so much strife across the
world sheriff joe lombardo heads one of
the largest police agencies in the
country
one that has vast experience in managing
large rowdy crowds
but he and others were surprised by the
anger
aimed at metro officers it was
eye-opening for me because i remember
when i first hired
if an individual was standing there and
got in my face
and said the things to me that they were
saying to my officers
in today's day it'd be a different story
i would probably lose my cool i watch
them i've seen video of them standing
there
with the worst things in the world being
hurled at them i mean people telling
them what they're going to do to their
wife
and their children right people these
people don't know these officers
and i watch these officers stand there
stoic and do their job as professionals
they can be
video images make it clear the police
pushed back
assorted agitators tried to incite
further trouble
a police car was torched an officer was
shot in the head
three militia members were arrested for
allegedly plotting to unleash molotov
cocktails
during a black lives matter event none
of this erupted in a vacuum for decades
las vegas was known for its tough cops
who didn't hold back
as for race las vegas was nicknamed the
mississippi of the west
well into the 60s the predominantly
black neighborhood known as the west
side
was viewed by police as hostile
territory
into the 80s it was a concern
of police officers to have to even work
that area you know it was considered the
battleground
of las vegas and through time that's
changed
change has occurred within metro but how
can it be measured
and is it enough more on that in our
next report
george knapp 8 news now the i-team was
given access to training
testing and transparency programs and
documents to see how metro measures up
tonight at 11 a look at key events that
led to major
changes within the agency